this next story would be the story in a
normal presidency if we didn't have this
temper tantrum government shutdown over
a non crisis at the us-mexico border if
we didn't have countless indictments and
convictions around Donald Trump and
Trump making threats to his personal
attorney about investigating his
father-in-law if Michael Cohen chooses
to testify before the Senate or the
house or whoever if we didn't have that
stuff the news that Jared Kushner a
close advisor to the president and his
son-in-law was rejected for a top-secret
security clearance but got one anyway
would be and it should be a front-page
story it's unfortunately barely a blip
but I am going to tell you about it
today
security clearance have been security
clearances in general have been an issue
for the Trump administration since they
took office
remember that Trump campaigned on
Hillary can't be trusted with sensitive
information or classified data or her
emails but then we found out that Trump
spilled secrets in the Oval Office to a
Russian spy recruiter we found out that
Trump had a whole bunch of people
working for him with temporary
clearances some of whom we suspected
couldn't even get clearances permanently
and Jared Kushner Trump's son-in-law and
advisor and someone who shouldn't even
be working in this capacity at all has
actually been rejected for that security
clearance but he got one anyway because
the supervisor decided to overrule the
decision of career security specialists
why was the determination made not to
give Jared Kushner security clearance
because of concerns about foreign
influence on Jared Kushner understand
that the normal process for getting a
security clearance resulted in Kushner
being rejected okay because he was too
under the influence of foreign powers
and individuals that decision was then
overruled by a supervisor and Jared
Kushner got his security clearance this
is
stunning because Kushner is number one
such a close advisor to Trump Kushner is
number two as a result of that so close
to endless sensitive information but
what's even more outrageous about this
is that it's not just Jared Kushner
there are an estimated roughly thirty or
more people working for Donald Trump
right now who were rejected from
security clearances on the merits but
then were overruled by a supervisor and
obtained those clearances anyway
everything is backwards the crisis at
the border that's not the crisis the
crisis is in the White House it's in the
Oval Office the sensitive information
liability wasn't avoided by voting for
Trump instead of Hillary Clinton it was
created by voting for Trump
instead of Hillary Clinton at least
thirty people should not have security
clearances and not only do they have
them they're working for Trump up to and
including in very sensitive and
privileged positions there's a national
security crisis right now it's not
people coming here for work from Latin
America it's all these people who
shouldn't even be involved in this stuff
who are making decisions about what our
government does and zoom out for a
second here okay the president was
investigated for being a Russian asset
countless advisors and staffers are now
being arrested indicted convicted sent
to prison in some cases because of the
Trump Russia investigation and the
dozens who haven't as of yet been found
to be criminals there are dozens who
were rejected from security clearances
but got them anyway and are now voting
for a working for Donald Trump
it's absolutely wretched it should be a
front-page story it made a blip and I
get it
there's a dozen crises every single week
there's a dozen or two dozen
embarrassments coming out of this White
House every single week but for the
party that claims to be concerned about
national security and protecting the
homeland and keeping people safe above
all costs there are people who were
rejected for security clearances because
of their potential or actual
we being under foreign influence who
ended up getting those security
clearances and are making decisions that
affect your security and that of your
family and that of your loved ones and
your friends that's the actual crisis
here not people trying to get a job who
are coming here from Mexico follow me on
instagram at David Pakman follow the
show on Instagram at David Pakman show
I'll be taking questions there tomorrow
we've got a great program coming up for
you today one of today's sponsors is
privacy comm slash Pakman this is a free
service that I've actually been using
myself for a while now and I love it you
just take a few seconds to link your
debit card or bank account to privacy
coms mobile app or browser extension for
Firefox and Chrome and what that does is
allow you to instantly create virtual
credit cards that are linked to your
bank account so that you're not actually
putting your real debit card number on
the Internet and you use these virtual
credit card numbers to buy things online
and with one click of a button you have
the ability to create multiple virtual
cards delete cards freeze and unfreeze
cards you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets 5 dollars towards your first
purchase when you sign up you
using that link below